hello everyone we've got a brand new
episode of the witching hour for you
we're gonna do the roll call again I'm
Perry that's Ali the more important
person in the room right now though is
Derek Mears no we are equally important
way to put it but you've worked on some
really cool oh where to even begin I
feel like the only sensible place to
begin right now is from the beginning
because I'm curious just because you've
carved out such a specific path for
yourself was it always like I want to
grow up be in Hollywood or did you ever
say I want to grow up and I don't know
like be like a doctor or a firefighter
or something like that
honestly I remember when I was younger I
was so into Dungeons and Dragons and it
wasn't cool to be into horror and comic
books oh you know at the time and I also
grew up the different kids I have a
disorder called alopecia and my hair
would fall out when I was younger and I
grew up in Bakersfield California and at
the time it wasn't cool to be white and
bald and if you were younger or like a
supremacist or like you know had a
cancer victim I'm not either no I got
respect but now I remember at one point
like I got into acting because a role
playing because I'm having a
conversation with my moms like what do
you want to be when you grow up I think
well I don't need to be rich or famous I
don't know I just want to create with my
friends and just play with my friends
and so this is the best way to do it and
so that's what how it kind of stem from
dungeon of dragons into acting and now
I'm just every time something comes
around I get wait I get it beware and be
who the play where yeah it still it
doesn't seem real I feel like I'm going
through it my toy chest as a child and
grabbing different iconic characters I'm
gonna try this one now okay I'm gonna
try this and if it ends today I'm like
so beyond thankful so it's crazy it's
real crazy
that's a coolest thing about like what
you specifically do too is it feels like
I mean every single actor needs to shed
their persona to basically lose
themselves in a new role but like with
all like the prosthetics and stuff like
you could do it to an extent that not
many can it's really cool cuz I rather
than as an actor I'm an all-around actor
but I my reps at one point for having
our conversations right you're a
professional act like why do you do the
make up stuff and I go because I'm a
professional nerd and I got this is fun
I go it's not about ego for me and it's
about creating and telling stories and I
go don't remember me remember the
characters the biggest compliment I get
on any show is when someone who goes oh
my god I didn't know that was you like
yes fantastic that makes me so happy so
yeah it's weird like bouncing to my
normal face and doing monsters from time
to time and I just whatever kind of
comes my way whatever kind of you know
theatrical board game like I'll roll the
dice and play so I'm lucky very lucky
well I mean that's great too because
your physicality you're very tall you
very large suits a lot of monsters and
creature things so it's big you're open
and happy about it
yeah one point when I moved to LA I
wrote my first big Hollywood job was
working at Universal Studios doing the
wild wild wild west done show where they
would take actors which I was at the
time I moved to do acting comedy and
they would crush her and to do stunts
and they took stunt people and crossed
her into act and a lot of they I would
go out with some of the stunt guys and
go hey we're gonna learn
air RAM or work on certain fight scenes
or Falls if you want to call me yeah for
sure because I found out if I worked out
I go wait I came back the big like the
big bad guy in TV and film I go oh my
god that's the best part likes so much
fun
and it just started taking off and I
started making a name doing both and it
got to the point about ten years ago I
had to stop doing the stunts I cuz a lot
of Hollywood can't believe you have two
skill sets though I still have the skill
set on things and I'll do things
secretly the time that I won't get
credited for but I but it's a weird
journey because they they see you as one
thing you know you're big guy with the
mask oh oh I've actually left producer
sessions where I go with God the mask oh
hey thank you so much have a good time
there why are you leaving I go because
if this is your mentality now and when
week three comes in your first layer of
skin is gone and you don't have that
respect there and you don't understand
what I'm bringing to the project I'm not
right for this I get go get your big guy
with a mask because that's not what I do
that's like a thing that happens in the
industry all the time I mean we
constantly talk about it on our shows
where we first meet an actor and they
wind up doing like a couple of the same
things and then they're completely boxed
into that so for
someone who's kind of up-and-coming and
makes making sure that they can keep all
those opportunities at their fingertips
what would you suggest that they do the
main thing is is to be you whatever what
makes you different step on that gas
pedal I always preach about in
interviews or doing Q&A or whatnot
because for myself like talking about
the alopecia when I was younger I
thought I was the different kid I was
the outcast I was the monster and what I
thought was my biggest weakness once I
moved to LA I went oh wait a second this
is my biggest strength so I went this is
amazing I feel like you know I'm kind of
walking the walk with things so when I
meet people and actors who are trying to
be like other people or I want to look
like you know Susan Sarandon or I'm like
Mila Jovovich I go no stop I go we're
all insecure about something but
whatever that insecurity is own it if I
come in on that and accept it and bring
that to the forefront that vulnerability
when you bring that vulnerability for do
you find out that so many I found out I
should say I get so excited also I
started ran point is that when you bring
that vulnerability for and the different
people in your life by showing that
vulnerability a lot of times they will
match that vulnerability and it enriches
your relationship to a deeper level so
I've kind of done it in a bigger sense
with the kind of the world where I'm on
this crazy Alice in Wonderland
journey in Hollywood they can end at any
time I've been doing it for 20 years and
I'm so thankful but if the more people I
can make friends with and go let them
know that it's gonna be okay and like
we're all have our skill sets in
different areas and no one's better than
anybody else like just I can share that
experience with more people so I just
I'm just very fortunate every day and if
it ends now
thank you everybody it's been a blast so
I know it's so cool that you could do
that because I think we're also talking
about the convention circuit although
it's just like using that opportunity to
be able to attend one of those in the
capacity you guys do and then be able to
get there up on stage and just I don't
know say something to an audience and
like someone out there might really need
to hear it at that point it's works is
it's not like a narcissistic thing I try
to constantly avoid that gonna I'm
talking about myself ago but if I can
share my experiences with people to
actually come on through a microscope
Bobby shared this experience Mapei
boy it makes me feel great now it makes
me feel great that I can take and I can
share that because I I always say I'm a
fan representing the fans even at the
cons were not my oh man like I get a go
here if I'm not doing a TV or a film job
I get to travel around the world meet
people who love the same thing that I
love and have a party for the weekend
but also meet older actors that I'm a
fan of that oh you want to go to dinner
and tell me what really happened you
can't tell the general public of the
movie that I like I'm trying to keep it
together right now and not nerd out
going well yeah that's awesome so aliens
did what just I lose my mind what's the
most starstruck you ever worried a con
oh gosh not so much a con it was
actually I usually don't get starstruck
at all anymore
but I was working on Sleepy Hollow the
TV show once and I had a reoccurring
back and forth and I came in half to my
van to go to work one day and he goes
hey we had another guy coming in just so
you know I'll hop in the back like I'm a
guest star I'm not like the regular cast
that's cool so I hopped in the back and
I'm waiting waiting and all of a sudden
Clancy Brown came in the front seat like
just it just it's one of those like not
ready for it at all and I knew that he
was on the show but I didn't know he's
working at this time and he was the
nicest gentleman in the world is it hey
is it okay if I stop by later on and
check out your makeup and I mean you can
do whatever you want I'm a huge fan of
your work and having you be a good solid
human being like this is cloud 9 for me
so just lucky lucky lucky lucky do you
remember your first long sit in a makeup
chair yes yes that was for a wild wild
west okay at the time it was a why was
I've done other films before that but
the Wawa West was my first introduction
to the Hollywood blockbuster and how
that operates like it was weird doing
like because I was hired for the
reshoots cuz they needed a bunch of big
bad guys I was the giant metal head guy
in the the spider and it was such a
crazy things there's times where like we
had like a 22 hour day
we had like the the makeup artist Ken
Diaz it might make at one point he was
asking because I hey we technically you
know we could pass right now but I
really like to work some of the detail
that's cool or something if you wouldn't
mind absolutely make it the best thing
possible and I think it was like nine
hours of makeup okay so luckily it's not
that all around but it was a great
learning experience I'm totally just
making this up right now but I'm
enjoying picturing it do you guys have
like like a creature actor like
community or friend group cuz like the
thought of like I don't know you Javier
Bois tent and Doug Jones having a dinner
party right but we've had those before
like like there's a small group of us
who are actors who also happened to do
makeup as well like Doug Jones and I
have been friends for years and we saw
ways like I hate being called a creature
performer and drives me crazy that's not
what I do it's an aspect of what I do
but a while back we had like a dinner it
was like Doug Jones Brian Steele and
myself and just comparing ideas and tips
and like cuz like you're kind of in your
own little realm but I just met via
Instagram and now become like I love
this guy like nobody's business
sales last name quickly a Reilly
shanigan who plays robot man on Doom
Patrol we have a mutual friend on the
show and like he must has been on social
media and he's new to some of the the
make up stuff he's a terrific guy a
terrific actor but we wouldn't had lunch
and had burgers and just you know
commiserated and just shared notes or
things like things you don't really
realize that the that other people
experience what wait you understand my
language like I was like when you it's
like we talked about at one point we had
like AI also Riley hope I'm not throwing
you in the bus there were knots let's
talk about any of this because I come
talking about it at one point like you
know what we're watching the episodes we
haven't seen yet of the programs that
were a part of and having that
detachment going oh that's the character
because we have that we see the
character through their own eyes and but
seeing the outside going oh is that what
everybody see is like oh okay because
I'm so emotionally into what's going
down
you know and not to see the outsides I
have a separation and at one point we
commiserate everybody's like do you have
like look like a traumatic flashback of
some of the emotional you know peaks and
valleys where I'm oh my god yes like a
watch I think I'll start to like tear up
or something like that because I my body
doesn't my body remembers it
but because but as an actor you're lying
to your body and going oh that trace oh
it's as if you're like reliving the
tragedy that you experienced onset and
then in your pretend land because we're
cuckoo crazy actors and seeing everybody
else enjoy going oh you love my misery
that's great yeah I was bawling for four
hours cool all right have a good time
guys
so I made like there's the the mental
demands of acting and everything and
also I think when you when you do as you
guys have embraced the extra level of
working with the prosthetic and I'm
genuinely curious what is your best like
stays and during the application removal
tip like for people who want to get into
it or anything like that how do you keep
your cool during those hours one is the
the breathe in the surrendering like
that relaxation and basically meditating
but also to me like before I got hired
for a Swamp Thing for example they were
asking like what's important to you and
I was trying to go look if you know I'm
not the right guy I've been doing this
for so long I know I will I want the
project to be the best thing possible so
if you need advice or I'll tell you and
on my end a lot of to take the stress
and the time away is like you really
have to enjoy the people you're around
so the makeup artists that I work with
and I'm so lucky to have Ozzy Alvarez
and Kevin Kirkpatrick who applied my
makeup because we're friends and like
you have to like people because you're
gonna have day is kind of like in a war
zone where you're locked in a trench
together and you're ready to murder
things around you're going is so
uncomfortable or something's going down
on set but these guys are so kind and
jovial and like we get along so well as
a family and it is it's not like work
it's like hanging out with your friends
and putting the makeup on kind of
surrendering because there are times
where it's like any minor little
irritant like with somebody like you
we all have we're all human beings
there's some people you flow with some
people you don't it's not
a positive negative either sighs its
some people your puzzle pieces affecting
some people you don't and sometimes
there's been people who like you know
one guy who would make jokes you know it
was one of those type of jokes who are
like for himself he's not making it for
a bit [ __ ] murder you poke your
eyeballs out stop making jokes I mean
it's it's like it's like you're not
doing this for anybody else's you're
just like jerking off and going for
everyone oh I hate your style a human I
can't stand you so after like three days
of that you start to get like you know
you're grabbing someone's hand or your
face going you're like if you put my egg
and I'm gonna I'm gonna rip your face
but if you like enjoy the people it's
such a different experience and like you
you really just kind of surrendered to
the Oh the whole experience cuz it's not
gonna be fun and luckily I go Swamp
Thing for example like it's the best
that it could possibly be and going into
it's like being a lifeguard and
complaining you get wet like you know
you're getting into so this just relax
and you know make the best of it you can
what's something about that process that
has changed since when you first started
that you're like thank God they made
that adjustment I I don't know if it's
changed but every time I guess is gonna
sound gross every time I get hired for a
job the first question to whoever
whatever company is designing the suit
is where is the escape hatch because I'm
I have a performance bladder where I'm
like I never want to be that guy you're
way down so I get called a set I'm only
thinking how do you rest him first okay
ready to go and we're focus on that not
thinking about that ever and there's
been times where oh yeah or hearing
horror stories going on yeah we didn't
put that in because it messed up okay
I'm not the right guy for this you have
to be able to maneuver that zipper and
if not like and also the art that's just
sounded we just met you're just like a
horrible human being
it was my bladder guys it's great
this is well it's great having a career
because after this comes out but else's
mastering in the years of you know
worried different monsters and different
monster hands and be able to work
suppose you know with like I have
pressure claws and I'm like okay now we
have how do you open this I'm a giant
you know muck person how do you
ridiculous so for me the zipper is the
one thing that over the years how they
hide it how to they put it into the air
design thank God for all of that because
if not I would be ruined right now I'm
curious if you had to live in one of
your games for one of your for one of
your movies what is the one you would
want to live in most and least the least
one would be though it's such an
impressive piece of art and don't take
any of this negative at all it was
Edward the troll from Hansel Gretel
witch hunters that was the most
difficult job sexual motion of my Cara's
all the burny burny is like I was sorry
say his last name wrong
iiiii eyes look like good person Bernie
who designed the other suit for that
also designed the Swamp Thing out but
how it all goes together and but the the
Hansel and Gretel outfit was so
difficult to work with but also such a
joy because the the studio wanted to do
it all CG and we kept going oh we can do
it practical with CG elements like let
us tap in that humanity I feel of you
all there's a there's a point in TV and
film with the CG and the practical come
mirror or meld together to make a great
final product but if it's just all CG
you lose some of the humanity in my
opinion you don't get the energy you
don't get the the paedos or the energy
that's going on you know for the
character and so I kept going like the
crazy one hunting Gretel I had a three
month shoot in Berlin and the first week
of shooting I was like mm a shape like
whatever I do I'm always like ready to
go for whatever that particular job is
and I was ready to rock a roll but week
1 because this the headpiece was so
heavy I got a herniated disc in my back
and we pushed through and I would get
like spinal injections
it was the most excruciating pain you
every time you put the helmet on it's
gonna collect its gonna grind your discs
together I mean yeah but I'm a huge fan
of dead snow and this is his first big
Hollywood thing I go I told you I give
you blood before we started I go if it
protects the performance like please
like replaced me with somebody else I go
but we can do this and we have the right
team together to pull this off the guys
from dead snow and they actually there
sorry no but we have are going to do
dads not to you and we have written to
you apart if they want to come to Norway
to shoot right now are you kidding me
and a lot of dead snow guys now our pals
of mine from Norway so when they come
into town like we'll hang out and
destroy my liquor cabinet which is
awesome it took me about a year but it
was it was real tough cuz that suit was
just a literal monster to do but also it
had to be and that's why I got hired to
do it because the art do these guys
created it's almost like having a
created a beautiful artwork that that's
a spaceship and I get to be the pilot
for it and you don't pilot it alone
because I can't tell you how to fix it I
can and some of the guys who actually
worked on the Edward outfit worked on
the Mars rover and some of the
technology is so cutting-edge I'm lovin
it but for the best suit I really the
ones where I'm not wearing suits I'm not
sure Twin Peaks man was so comfortable
wearing that fake face that wasn't mine
getting beat up so that was great yeah
yeah then a lot of that I don't like
working on halo and some of the lower
ring games and whatnot that's always
just a blast like a confession of my
backgrounds all improv comedy where I've
done improv professions I was seventeen
and so I especially when you do
performance capture or
like using your imagination in mind like
an OS this is just like a higher-end
improv show we'll let you put that
scripted so it's fun
well I we said we loved Hansel and
Gretel which others are so happy I think
that bad design not suits one of the
most incredible prosthetic things I've
seen likewise The Swamp Thing is a
gorgeous design where does that suit fit
on your scale of miserable - wearing a
mess honestly this suit is the best that
it could possibly be and I've said
before in other interviews I was in
dating myself Cadillac of suits and it
really really is like the thought that
Justin Rowley and fracture defects put
into this is just above and beyond
because sometimes with some shops like
what they say what they're gonna do for
the for the run of the show end up at
the very minimal in or they'll to meet
the requirements of what they said
they're going to do but Justin would do
the opposite and knowing how long I had
to be in the suit for you know seven
eight months he would dip into his own
profits just to make it right and also
knowing James wons passions his work
with James so many times they they
wanted to be the best thing possible
because also a majority of us you know
on the team are nerds for Swamp Thing
and so we're going to host as our shots
like put our mark and to you know make
the family this is for the fans and I
tell you it's the thing is just gorgeous
and when I first met with them there was
like they're like is there anything that
you can think of like new things or
things that haven't even been done
before that you would like or can would
like to talk about for the suit and out
of the six things that I brought up no
one's ever done and they did it could
you make is it possible to give event
because sometimes if you're you're
you're inside the suit and when you're
doing emotional scenes that you heat up
there's nowhere for the energy and they
did it okay it's like everything I name
about they put in and went above and
beyond and it's the it moves so well
because a lot of times when you do a
makeup job when you're looking in the
mirror like seeing what you have to work
what is it's almost like if you're a
wreck a race car drive you're seeing how
the brakes were you're saying how the
accelerant and how is it reading for
camera same thing with the emotions and
you might have to turn something up a
little bit more and kind of reset your
your neutral baseline
like with Acura in general like I'm a
little more animated than most people so
I for straight-acting I have to back off
and kind of dull it a little bit so it's
it's normal because you know you're not
gonna be an emotional conversation with
hey wait a second like not moving and
bring it down but something for makeup
stuff like you have to figure out what
that neutral line is and with this I
didn't really have to do anything there
are scenes like I'm watching the show
because I don't want to watch the
Monarchs I don't want to affect my I
don't want to get in my head what the
performance is because it's coming
through me and I'm feeling and that's
always if you're feeling and it's always
right so I would watch them the show
with my wife now and oh my oh is that
how that that emotions that's pretty
moving so uh so yeah that's my all so
please feel free to cut me off at any
time like you'll ask me like you can go
like Derrick what's your favorite cowboy
and you'll be like I will go back to
when I was five years old I opened my
first shut up gin and juice storytelling
so the doors open for you to continue as
much as you want
please very curious what you thought
when this opportunity first crossed your
path because we've had some other do you
see all access shows come our way but I
still imagine when then pitch to you
that was still in its like infancy yeah
I'm gonna throw people gonna hate me
first like I'm pretty sick what I when I
first went I was on the short list for
the character and my my reps contacted
me they could hey you have a meeting of
our Warner Brothers they want to see you
for this project a project they're doing
a new Swamp Thing okay cool like here's
you know all the sides they wonder have
you read okay so I went in and read and
did my thing and met all the producers
and the showrunners and what I left and
my rep called and was like hey my man is
like so how'd it go I go huh pretty well
I go I think I'm I think I'm in the
number one position I had I had that
feeling from the my I don't know for
sure he goes no that's what we think too
like oh my and he was getting excited
are you not excited I go well to be
honest my friend I go I just don't
understand how you're gonna
like not like a pg-13 all-access you
know CW swamp things show how you gonna
pull that off so I'm not really that
stoked about it and he's like Derek it's
the DC Universe it's hard are they're
following the Alan Moore is a Bible it
goes it's a horror drama it's what
they're going for and I go wait wait
what I'm sorry and then I never know
who's who or what who's done what cuz I
had that big equality thing going oh
we're all artists in different mediums
and you know we work together as a team
so there's no like I'm this guy and then
he started naming off who was in the
room and what their accomplishments were
and I'm like oh oh oh and something they
called back and said hey we're gonna
have you come back in we're gonna have a
reader with you were gonna have like a
female actress this time and we have a
couple more scenes who would like to see
how you play off of her you know for
this role and I'm like okay cool that's
when they kind of get in start getting
like worried going but um the funny
thing about it was when I was leaving
the is a fun story Rex's inside singer
let's hold on with us when I was leaving
the the second time and I go hey can I
ask you guys a quick question being you
have ties with DC and Warner Brothers
and I go it's about an obscure DC
character and they go yeah sure what
what do you what do you want to know and
I go like an a-list writer a friend of
mine we were talking about exploring a
property and possibly expanding our
property but we didn't know it's movie
if there's anything any traction on them
right now no yeah just fire away what
character and I go well it's my favorite
DC character I go uh the Blue Devil and
they all froze nobody move and there's
like it's like you sucked air out of the
room and everyone is stared at me and
nobody moved and what oh you cannot tell
me if something I can just exit the room
that's fine that way it's always a
secret like Gary da Thurman was so
awesome like this is like this is how
when you first meet somebody you store
that moment in your head Gary Bauer was
like yeah I'll tell them because maybe
that character will show up as soon as
the
the second episode of the the project
that you reading for and I was like so
ridiculous so ridiculous so yeah I was
super stoked to see that they you know
the cast you know irons earring and
who's the sweetest human being in the
world in the role and it's just been a
real Alice in Wonderland journey and I
am to see where it continues to take
manner it's a I mean I think a lot of
people had sort of your read on it
before it came out though which is like
how do you do this
yeah not knowing how hard are it was
going to be and it comes through I'm so
happy because even for we're doing the
we're shooting the show like nobody ever
talked about like superhero though he is
technically a superhero it's all horror
drama and the the way Mark verheiden and
Gary Doberman ran their writers are like
everyone was just so freaking cool on
the show and talented but everyone
wanted each department to fire and on
all cylinders it just wasn't one of
those Hollywood clock-in I think I've
never done it but I've seen people kind
of like oh I'm just doing this and
they'll clock in and I what's the
minimum I have to do they did blood in
my life all right later
and what do you do but everybody would
put put that extra effort and we all
felt it early on whether there was
something special and we kept talking
about it I remember Virginia Madsen
talking about it going we would have
get-togethers at her house is on Sundays
and we would the cast producers we'd all
hang out together and didn't had this
bonding of a family but right off the
bat and it was it's kind of heard of for
a show to do that but well felt it was
something special and it was so
interesting also you know having the
script to go from but realizing there's
certain scenes like you know when you're
hanging out with some friends of
somebody before you actually do things
together or whatnot and what with our
take is so you don't know you know your
color you know you know your your puzzle
piece that you're bringing to the table
but you have an idea what the overall
picture is gonna be but you don't know
for sure but finding out that everyone
is playing it like check off and no one
is like winking at the camera and if
there's an emotional scene everyone is
just going full-bore going
oh and that ticket for tat for going
like oh you did what okay cool I'm gonna
match you and do this and it was really
a group effort like to make it the I
keep saying before the best thing
possible and like there be times like
people would have days off and what you
would never hear they would just come in
to hang out on set and go yes you know
cool cool I'm like oh so that the family
feel between cast and crew like the
Wilmington crew was just so passionate
about it and they knocked it out of the
ballpark it was such a heartbreaker to
find out you know after our first
episode that we got cancelled for the
second season but all we've heard up
into that point was like how amazing
everything was and it was going we have
a big hit on our hands like this is
crazy oh my god I don't want to hear any
of that my relationship between me and
my art but knowing and loving everybody
on board that got me excited going oh
for them that's cool so it's a weird
like nebulous space that we're all now
because we don't know officially why
that would happen or why they canceled
it even if you are gonna cancel wouldn't
you wait until later on to see how it
plays a fan before going on some well to
people like this is over why like don't
tune in I guess because it's wasn't even
just that I mean it seemed it seemed
very bizarre to me that the cancellation
happened when it did because not only
like were you guys and also you talking
about a family and having had such a
good experience making the project but
they also got good reviews and they
don't hear about that but even before
when you found out that this the episode
lineup was going to be shortened ya
understand how you process that while
you're working we have the the greatest
people on board like at scene I was
worried at first cuz you know so as
opposed to having a guest star or being
on a feature you know your full
character arc and you're you're planning
with this you know I'm still planning my
character arc but I don't know the total
end because it's still coming is gonna
conveyor about all scripts where I I'm
shooting 104 or 105 I'm getting them
soft memorized getting prepared and it
just kind of keeps coming and keeps
coming so you're kind of speculating
where you're kind of Arc is going to be
or where you're going and it was so
crazy on we were on
ten when we got the call going on yeah
so we're getting cut to 10 from 13 we're
like what also reading the script for 11
going no okay so I was worried at first
we had a week or so a week or two weeks
to to redo everything and execute it so
it all makes sense and I was worried
going I don't know how we're gonna get
this all together because we've been
laying so many beautiful puzzle peas and
the complexity these writers are doing
it's just what a gift absolute gift to
be able to perform with and seeing what
they did and having the new like them
like with get together and just work
their sleepless nights putting it all
together going and handing out the
script for the new ending and going like
oh my god like this works like I don't
know how you guys did this you guys are
magicians like I am on board for this
and I understand you know where we where
that's going and what not going oh I was
just so happy but I was you know
honestly worried because also knowing
how but the sacrifices the cast and crew
made to be there and for each other and
also like I talked about it before I
kind of tweaked or in the blood sweat
and tears are literal like their stuff
that went down and people leaning on
each other as a team for myself but that
to me is the most important thing where
it doesn't matter if you're the guy in
the editing room you know the crazy late
hours with no one around you you're the
editing the show if you're the the
working in the mold department you know
to make like an extra like Swamp Thing
here or something going you're you're a
cog in this giant machine your
fingerprint is a part of this we're all
together I'm lucky to be the the
figurehead and sometimes I know because
people oh you're that guy oh thank you
so much like the compliment you're
giving me doesn't just go to me it goes
to everybody on here because it takes a
team to make something like this happen
and I just I'm very proud of what we did
but also very saddened by the sense of a
lack of respect go and we have a brand
new baby we worked so hard on and having
someone like slit their throat and go
here's the baby in going like oh yeah no
more baby after this why would you do
so I don't know but overall lucky to
have the opportunity to do that and the
people and friends that I've made off
this we're gonna be friends for forever
and they're they're good human beings I
like that you could spin it positively
in the end because at the very least at
least we still have like a complete
season that was able to be turned on
despite that one hiccup towards the end
yeah we got a 10 hour movie which is
great and it's something that I think
there's elements that we want as fans
and that we executed and I feel that
we've pulled off and it's better to do
that than have done nothing at all and
who knows like maybe something will
switch somewhere if something will flip
and we can all get together again and
but I tell you it's one of the best
experiences I've had and set the bar
really high for working together with
her with a group of people that's what I
was wondering I mean is there any is
there any chance to save it and bring it
bring it somewhere else find a different
Avenue thank you specially you guys find
so much success the first time around
Yeah right I don't understand why
someone wouldn't want to grab that I
kept going that to it to mark for hiding
our showrunner and I got when we were
shooting they go I don't I kept going
thank you like I said I don't I don't
know how you on the cast side is not
knowing how because he didn't read
everybody together knowing people's
chemistry I don't know how you cast that
way to kind of capture this lightning in
a bottle of good people and working
together without no one being a problem
and thus ending with the the crew like
to bring these people who are so
passionate and talented but it's little
like showing up with your friends and
going let's create art together what do
you need for your art oh you need that
okay for mine I needed this like how do
we oh we go this way oh okay a little
and it's like that to me is like the
biggest thing at all I need to see
everybody get respect because sometimes
you know there's a there's the
unfortunate as a hierarchy onset and
people like oh I'm just this person I
know what you you're the caterer I can't
make food for 260 people that's your
skill set like that's your art like I
play pretend I go that so there's no
hierarchies that we work together so it
just it just felt so good the entire
time and yeah it's such a weird weird
thing this all went down but even my
managers recently he goes you have
people
calling to check out to check on you
through me to see how you're doing
and he's like Derrick's fine I'm taking
this harder than Derek is and he's like
it's part of the business I don't like
that is partly this is like a you can't
control it so why am I gonna fight it so
I always want to be known personally for
my career like people talk about like
awards that's Oscar I don't give two
shits about any of that like what I want
to be known for is like oh that guy did
good work like he moved me like whatever
his passion was like oh he got to do his
passion and that to me I'm just like
yeah done doing good work yourself but
talking about the mentality in the way
that you approach projects it also seems
like you help bring the best work out of
others and just hearing that kind of
approach to everything is like really
heartwarming to me you tried and my
experience over the years of doing this
you you really want to create that
that's safe creative space because I've
been in that spot like that the hardest
thing and you can do in the acting
business is is auditioning and coming in
as a guest or a co-star because you're
the new kid at school every day is a
first day for you there's people who
have other ongoing relationships they
know the flow they know the tone of the
show and you're the one like you stand
here do this okay you don't know anybody
and do your three-page monologue now cry
no okay hey man you so all this
pressures all around you and we had a
thing on the show which was so I'm so
happy because it wasn't like a spoken
thing it just kind of happened where
we'd have guest stars come in and I
personally would try to dissipate a lot
of the fear and going like hey man I go
here's how the show is we're not titling
a word-for-word as long as you get the
main idea across here's the tone of the
theme since the show hasn't been out
everyone's playing it like check off you
know playing a dead stray and a member
Scottie dexhart who's one of our guest
star that reoccurring guest star he is
like the sweetest human being we hit it
off great news I can't he's I've never
been treated like this before you're
treating me like a regular Casper you'd
go out to the bars are gonna have drinks
and have dinner and I to be included and
treated equally you want axe-throwing
and you guys invited me this is so weird
to go no you understand we're all in the
same boat cuz once the show goes down
we're all
in the same you know unemployment line
so why not be cool but that was the
mentality where if you had a safe play
full space that's where your best work
comes from because you can take those
risks and you're not worried about
someone like freaking out and yelling at
you and so you have that even if
something's not working out you know
it's not working why don't we try this
but in a sense of doing the Improv side
of things whether you saying yes and
going oh what do you need for your thing
okay I don't see it that way but I'm
gonna try to make it work let's try that
and if it doesn't like someone else will
tell us and it was such a fun creative
process I can Derry stop saying all the
positive stuff give us the dirt it's
like it's also impressive because
genuinely from what you said from what
James Wong said on social nobody
understands why or how there have been
so it seems they could be the kind of
thing that's so easy to get angry about
and I just have a lot of respect for
[ __ ] healthy approach you have taken to
it I'm always that guy though also like
even if I've have a loved one million
passed away I remember at one point was
talking to my mom's funeral and I go I
know everyone I was speaking at the
funeral going look I understand it
everyone is so sad and like it's our
time to more because mourn because well
that's what we do as human beings we
Sierra them but morality or mortality
within you know people's deaths and we
feel that loss of love I go but I choose
to see it as that I've got to have this
person as my mother for all these years
and I would rather have those years to
not have those years and going I'm the
lucky one who got to be her son and so
we all had that moment where we can all
you know I choose to I know how she is
and she would choose to celebrate
because he wasn't just a mom for me she
was a mom just so many people and she
had that that nurturing instinct and I
go so I choose to celebrate this going
hey we all got to have her in her life
and like let's celebrate that side of
things whether being bummed out still
deals still be bummed out which is fine
then also refer to get personal we're
the funeral home and like there's an
open field behind me I was talk
in a podium and I go and also that
Greenlawn mortuary and and cemetery of
actually and in honor for my mother have
actually been in its July have a you
know I've decided to do a firework show
for her so you know you know so take it
away Greenlawn we did this I waited for
a good full minute or something like
that until one of my friends who knows
me is like there's no oh that's right
because I'm lying
okay so enjoy your day and everyone like
it gave that levity and everybody broke
then every started kind of been telling
the stories about like oh my god so I'm
that guy who's like I try to like I'm
human like I have my good days in my bad
days I'm not a saint at all like I try
to have similar to swamp thing to have
that strive for that balance so like all
the stuff that goes down or the show
going like man we got to be together I
got to work with some of the most
talented people in the industry and we
also it got captured on camera and
people are enjoying it and hearing that
it's moving people you know that's
that's all you could wish for and if if
it I said before of it everything ends
now it's been a great run so no no
regrets I think you just reinforce
something that we talk about all the
time which is like everybody in the HAR
community it's like we all make you know
like like dark bloody gory stuff but I
don't know it all it all comes from like
art like a really sweet and heartfelt
place it just seems like horror
filmmakers we've met are some of the
most loving warm people out there it's
the craziest I was just happen I was
just doing a con like last weekend in
Vegas and I had this conversation aware
there are some people it's one person
was like oh I'm new to it I'm a horror
fan but I've never been to economise
welcome to the family and I try to give
the breakdown from my experience I mean
they go as an actor I go through
different genres of you know of film and
I know there's different fans on Rah's
and I go the horror fans out all the
other fans that I've experienced I don't
know it's because we've all felt like
outcasts a certain times or not accepted
they are the nicest human beings in the
world I've told the story over and over
where I've literally seen people in like
my lines like to come say hi which I'm
so thankful for someone will have like a
John Carpenter's
the things shirt on and someone's like
next to them you know very you know you
know introverted anyway oh you like the
thing yeah it's my favorite movie - oh
cool we're friends
all right cool we're friends and then
later on you see them hanging out at the
bars together cons later you see them
hanging out going like oh my god this is
like the nicest group of people in the
freaking world so weird you say I was
just at a Vegas con we were online at a
taco stand and the buddy that I was with
was wearing a really cool Spiderman
shirt and the person standing in front
of us wasn't even going to the con turns
around he goes awesome shirt man a hot
place for like something like 30 40
minutes oh like I think we need have
more in the world in general were so you
you find the common things either you
can relate to other things that
different that are different going oh
always wearing that so he's cool he's
got that spider-man shirt I like which
one is it okay that's a good one yeah I
feel like we're hanging out I want to
ask you guys questions the hey I'm going
so will you go delicious of like shut up
Derek we've been here the whole time
you're the new person we could talk
about all this kind of stuff all I mean
we pretty much do we come close to it at
least yeah I do have another burning
question you have worked with so many
incredible people in this industry who
are they drunks okay first off if you
could pick one person that you've yet to
work with that is like on the top of
your list who would it be
oh my god that's a really good question
I don't know I've got to the point also
lifeWise like spiritually I've just kind
of surrendered and went like where do
you need me the most like whatever
happens happens and that's the way I let
my kind of compass go and guide me but I
never really think about like ah that
person some day this is a real tough one
my I don't have a gaff avorite I like
actor or people who do you know who you
look up to I go just creation in general
the person that rocks my world is a
musician but early on I heard him
in an interview about talking about
creativity and like breaking your own
walls and like coloring outside the box
and my things that would not normally be
associated with what you're doing - you
need to incorporate that to take risks
for risk and reward and then going here
you're gonna fail but he's really
inspired me about just like an open
creativity and that that gentleman is
Mike Patton who is the lead singer lot
people known for Faith No More but he's
had so many other albums and other
groups since then he'll do he studied at
John with John Zorn or the theater voice
in San Francisco and to find out he's
the one that when they did that survey
outlying where was I who has the highest
you know the biggest range as a singer
male singer and everyone's know it's Axl
Rose and then later on oh we're
attracted actually it's Mike Patton but
I have the range but he would do songs
like in Portuguese he would do you know
I he'd add a rap that once I didn't
switched John Roos in the middle of a
song and go to a different style and
just push all these different boundaries
I just found out that he's doing all
this music for Joe Hill's AMC's
nosferatu and I'm like oh I want to see
that so to me that that guy I also never
want to like meet him because if he ever
turned out to be a jerk it wouldn't
crush me creatively like I just love his
work and like I mean but it would be
cool to do to work with him in a sense
like whenever he scored something to be
a part of it like I would love to do
like us like a attention building silent
scene and have him do the music - that
that to me but but um but there's so
many it's it so hard there's so many
talented people out that I would just
love to work with and it's just like
it's like being a fake a foodie and
going to let your favorite food I'm like
there's so many what are you baby I mean
even just looking at horror which is not
all that you do there are limitless
options you're very sweet so no I mean
it's true you're you're kind of all over
the place in your career like you said
you don't just do the costume stuff you
should work on TV films or every call
for do you have a is there something
that you love to do the most like do you
like the production process of film or
than television or do you like having
the as you said the scripts laid out so
that you can do a full character arc
if on the that side there's there
there's something that I prefer than
anything else but I just love when
you're in that zone where similar to it
there's there's seven different forms of
intelligence and even if you're not into
something to somebody else is doing I
remember when I was younger younger many
knew about and oh but I was younger and
I saw like slipping through channels I
saw Ben Folds playing a piano and I
didn't know who he was I didn't know
he's anybody was plain I'm like a
percussion instrument later on to find
out that he's a drummer originally and
so he learned piano to play a certain
way and I would just mesmerized so
there's there's certain things about for
certain performances no matter what your
art medium is is even if you're not into
but when you see when someone's so
connected to whatever it is they're
doing that you lose track of time it's
that in the zone where like I don't know
how many I long I've been watching this
like I don't know okay I got you're a
basketball player will be on fire you
know and like you know hidden shot spot
shot that's that creative zone I just
like I love Cena and also I love being
in it because there's times like on
Swamp Thing where there are certain
parts where there's there's such a mania
some of the experiencing because he's
going to this existential crisis and
you're literally just kind of tearing
your own you know the walls are your own
inner self house and tearing them apart
and questioning when I away there's
really nothing behind here and losing
your mind in a sense but having though
those days where died I don't what did
we do that's the last shot oh how long
oh we've been here 14 hours okay cool
and not knowing that it's just gone by
because you're so focused and in
connected to whatever you're doing I
love those moments and that to me it's
like that Shakespeare one foot and dream
one foot in reality and when you could
lose yourself and just focus on the art
and just kind of surrender whatever the
whatever you believe in or I could
create a force that kind of comes
through us that to me is like the
ultimate the high in a sense so I know
that at that answer your question
okay thank God what do you do for fun
give me random hobbies I have six
animals which I do you even have I swear
every single witching hour we always ask
our guests if they have any pets oh yeah
I'm a ding dong of an animal person so
yeah we have three dogs and three cats
oh they take up a lot of my time and we
have a he's almost turned 2 now we have
a box key puppy and a box he is he's a
half boxer half husky and we my wife and
I oh I rescued him or my wife and I
rescued him and we kept going he's
getting bigger
he's getting Oh is he gonna stop growing
he's about 80 pounds now the world would
live there the the prepubescent you know
or it's like the teenager stage where
I'm trying to figure out where he is in
the pack and I'm like what's his name
it's Charlie Atari puppies like we don't
buy animals for like the way they look
we're like oh you're a handsome dude so
yeah he is just an absolute tree but I'm
but animals read I used to do video
games all the time but then I found this
new thing called books where I should
actually I feel more substantial when
I'm done I don't feel hollow like it's
done I just I saved the universe that's
okay not in no way but just because I
just by like for do you but I'm gonna
try this I'm gonna get back into it so I
am on board with it but um yeah well you
guys are - I'm actually working on
reading more at the moment really cuz
it's it's one of those things that's too
easy not to give yourself time to do I
am listening to audiobooks well I'm
training for my marathons what training
for a marathon first one in November how
long how many miles
26.2
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what I'm gonna get there
nothing but respect like that is cuckoo
town baby puppy pictures and then you
see where he is now as an adult no this
is his eyes crazy blue like I put his
name in you type in box key in Google I
don't know if it's still there but he
used to be like all his ton of his
pictures I'm like oh he's a star
Charlie's doing it specific dog now but
do a lot of them have the blue eyes I
don't know I really don't but he is just
he's such a character so just the traits
of a husky and a boxer mixed together
we're with the chirping and the talking
and the attitude but he has us ever
since he was a puppy like it's so weird
my wife and I could go in what is his
deal he has a side eye thing where he's
like it's almost like you like it's like
Sam Jackson just her like caught you
like no talking crap about him where
he's like hey you know know but there's
no emotion behind it he's just like oh
no I owe you if you yell at I'm going I
try no you know how to chew that it'll
sit back like that that power stands and
just kind of excited I really are you
done you're not even afraid like you're
the cat version of that is just like
you're not allowed to do something it's
just sitting there like that's exactly
but if you want something else which
full-on disney eyes where his ears are
like almost like a loop all the way
around it either they're super big like
are you gonna eat that piece of bacon I
know we're not supposed to eat bacon
right now and all the other dogs in the
room but if you want to give me between
okay do you want to do our last
recurring question because especially if
you're reading right now now I'm like
force feeding you a medium to go with
but we wrap every interview with this
question yeah it doesn't have to be
books it can be books comic books
anything you want webseries movies film
those are the same back and listen to
the interview what oh my god he sound
really confident I'll be so redundant
eager like did I make sense
so you are totally fine okay
wait what's like exciting you right now
in the genre something you've seen read
heard that's just like you're digging it
this that's all so this is a great
question by the way because I also love
like when you when you ask people I've
gotten on the plane with TV and film
we're telling modern myths and so we
only have we have our own personal myth
outside of that come a big joseph
campbell fan and so what i'll try to get
to know somebody i'll ask like what
they're like favorite film is and also
what's the film you've seen the most
because that's kind of like the you
don't want to admit to it but there's
something you see would find out
something about their own personal story
that ties into that film because art is
so subjective so you find out going oh
you like for scout because and like a
little like subtextual thing so uh what
am i into right now uh what am i cuckoo
crazy about I'm still stuck on I'm
digging Mandy like I know I saw it a
while ago but I still like the movie
Mandy I just like I love the creativity
and like the there were some shots like
I would I'm when I saw in the theater
for the first time I would tear up and I
would look at the person I think about
how how do you get that shot like just
that that alone is that still it's just
freaking gorgeous what else what else oh
this is a good question and I'm just
failing and flailing with Mandy I'm
reading savage Avengers which I'm really
enjoying from the
there's all kinds of I've also do the
thing when I'm reading books like I had
like five different books I'm reading
all at once in it but I'm also like I
need a focus on what yeah so much it
just it's so strictly the opposite where
even if I put a book down for a little
I'll never let myself go to the next one
without finishing that one info cuz my
brain just can't oh here's something in
general my my wife and I like I'm so
lucky I'm married the right woman like
you don't exist on paper we both love
schlock movies where we like if it's
like 7:00 o'clock and we don't have like
anything in Hollywood to do you know
Hollywood shuts down we mean like we
have like the Oscar screeners going no
no we want to watch like dinosaur
you know bathroom booger monster 7 like
makeup you whatever yeah it's real bad
or you know real bad Indies we always
say a lot of times my look we have an
ongoing speech where right okay
someone made something so freaking hard
to do hats off to you with that said
let's see what we got it's a lot of them
are not so good but it's not what it's
not a hate watching thing all right oh
this guy what an idiot we will Mystery
Science Theater and talk out loud that's
the rules but I find such joy and like
going like wait how did you think that
would work or seeing what you're doing
and going oh like okay I see where it
fell apart but every now and then you'll
find somebody who wrote directed starred
and produced the film and you're like oh
man like if you just stuck with the
writing like that part is really really
good not not poopoo anything else you've
done but like that you've really got a
skill set there but I just I love like
the the weird creativeness of things and
like seem also people can always get
better each time they do something and
grow so it's like I said it's not a diss
at all but I honestly have such a
passion of going like oh what is this
like yeah an old it's like she we go to
cons there's anything about cause my
wife would come back hey I found
something this just called like
killdozer it's like Christine but with a
bulldozer my love
yes I wanna see that right now are you
kidding me
so she'll find his crazy treasures and
like I just love going down these rabbit
holes like we're going now we're going
through all the old Andy Sedaris films
through full moon right now I know
Picasso trigger or a hard ticket to
Hawaii it's just so cheesy and good like
we're also going through you see the
laughs that I brought this up
do think about things we're into right
now we're going through the old Lorenzo
Lamas renegade series which is super
awesome but we also play it like the
show so much from the bull play it's
almost like you're watching a WWE show
where like you get behind like some of
the cheesiness that they're going like
like a lot of times like that's not no
no but if I could arrest me what yeah oh
yeah excuse me you're talking to a guy
who's wanted for a crime that he did not
commit so maybe you don't know and like
many a times like someone will say
something like you know like so you got
a problem stranger and I'm like karate
shirt I'm like oh here it comes like
yeah teach him a lesson with your boots
my phone ability we're so into like we
love the cheese factor but also it's
it's not like I said not making fun of
it like we love it it makes me so sad we
have to wrap this everybody out there
knows because we talk about it often
DC all-access swampthing go give it a
watch is there any like personal social
media or other projects you want to play
I mean I have my own stuff where I I
have my own I run my own social media I
don't have a manager or somebody else to
excite ways try to open that curtain up
for oz and Hollywood and from time to
time I'll try to get back to people but
also it's gotten the point where so much
now we're on my own I trying to be a
jerk I don't return your message
but it's just at Derek Mears I'm
basically all the platforms and I also I
have a show that I do called the
resistance where it's a live show here
in LA we do at UCB on sunset
the last Sunday of every month now we've
taken a break because we're all in the
industry and we're all over the place
and I've been gone in seven months so we
decided to do one show a month just so
we all can get three guys but what we do
is it's a long form we improvise an
action-movie live on stage and we have a
keyboardist who scores it live we have a
guy in the booth doing lights and sound
effects but what makes our show unique
is we have a bunch of different stunts
pads kind of giant Lego blocks will
build scenes will do full improvise
fights there's ladders ropes water
bottles it's crazy we tell the audience
that we've I've been doing improv since
I was 17 or we'll tell the audience to
be going look we don't know what's gonna
happen but it's not our show it's all of
our shows included the audience so we
might come out to you and do a scene in
the audience we might have you come up
and join us we there's no secret in or
like Harold format like we don't know
what's going on but we tell like these
long-form narratives that make sense
and like I don't know how they keep
we've been doing it for so many years
and they make it just like the odd it's
like wait you guys you guys talked about
that you built a giant helicopter out of
a ladder and a jump rope you know but it
made you guys are playing dead serious
alright yeah we don't know how this all
comes together but it makes sense that
we just have a blast doing it but we do
that it's called the resistance comedy
on social media and I love performing
with those guys because I also you guys
ever want to go we'll get you tickets
cuz it's just a playtime with friends
but yeah we've been selling out at UCB
and letting a lot of hype on that which
is pretty fun and yeah we do a lot of
makeup ups no scripts involved you just
go congratulations on everything and
thank you for being a real delight in
this thing we need more positivity and
good attitudes and just someone who
wants to spread good like you do thank
you for having me on your platform
congratulations on a success and also
thanks for being good humans yourself I
feel like I've known you forever I'm
like oh that's right we're doing
interviews everyone find you on the
Internet you can find me at Haley foutch
on Twitter and that haystack mcgroove e
on instagram and i'm at p Nemiroff on
Twitter and Instagram
that's it guys you have officially
survived the witching hour
you